first step later today for the clark  county school district it's been more  than 300 days since most  students have been on campus in ccsd and  tonight the school board considers a  plan that could start sending some of  them back  about 46 percent of the school large  school districts around the country has  have moved past this phase of distance  learning  and are now in some phase of reopening  so that leaves about  54 that are still with us in virtual  learning  citing academic and the mental  challenges of distance learning this  latest recommendation from ccsd is for  small groups of students to voluntarily  return to their campuses  trustees can also still consider a  hybrid schedule at tonight's meeting  we'll have complete coverage later  on 8 news now